[Music]
well ladies and gentlemen we're over
1600 i want to thank everybody once
again for the subs today
and we're going to get one more gaming
ten minute game we're over 1600
let's go
okay so we haven't faced the english yet
and um i'm gonna play this in principled
fashion let's go e5 let's play the
reverse sicilian for sba thank you for
the prime
now
as you might know
we play the alep and sicilian with white
against the sicilian
and the reverse allopin is a very much
viable system against the english
um and it's quite theoretical it's very
popular in a recent date in recent times
bishop g2 is already inaccurate
white is supposed to strike at the
center or go knight f3 now this allows
us to go d5 and control the center we
basically play this as if we're on the
white side of an elephant
oop g3 and e3
so a very passive setup by our opponent
here
very passive setup by our opponent
here um
which doesn't necessitate anything
in particular on our part
just uh normal development i think will
suffice
knight c6 knight f6
it doesn't really matter which pieces we
developed first here
pronoun's pushing a heck of a lot of
pawns
let's go knight f6
knight e2
now
some of you may know that i like to play
e4 in such positions
but if you play e4
prematurely well what's the downside
white might go d3
and it might be hard to sustain that
pawn on e4
so that makes sense if you play it
without sufficient development it's
going to potentially might backfire
d5 being a weakness is not such a big
problem because we're defending it
well bishop e6 queen d7 and long castle
is an idea but with the c file being
open
and with white having uh
quite easy pawn pressure i don't think
we should be castling queen side here at
least i i feel like it's needlessly
risky
um we could give e4 a shot and see what
happens but i prefer conventional
simple
development so where should this bishop
go we can go to e6 safeguard pawn on d5
very conservative move but um
you know that
there's no need to you know
rediscover the wheel
and distribute the code vaccine all at
once now we have a couple of approaches
that we could take here we could
definitely go h5
um we could play queen d7 i like the
move queen d7 a lot as a way to start
because it's very flexible we're
preparing bishop h3 in some cases but
we're not necessarily committing to
anything in particular
okay
now once again there's
this is one of those positions i'm
struggling to communicate this where
there are so many different ways you can
develop and play and all of them are
probably approximately equivalent
but once again we're adhering to the the
general strategy of completing our
development before embarking on anything
specific so
i'd like to develop this bishop well
where should we develop it
one thing to keep in mind is that white
is very likely to play d4
and then after e4
you might notice that white's knight
might jump onto f4 that's quite an
annoying square so by playing bishop d6
we're preempting that we're preparing to
take that knight b4
right now i think
it's high time for us let's let's go
with the attacking approach i think
we've completed our development
i think now
we could go for the attacking approach
let's go h5 and i'm not worried about b5
we just drop our knight back this is a
paper tiger
let's go h5 h4 you know the drill we've
had a million games in the hippo
where we've we've won precisely in this
way the purpose of this is to open the h
file then bishop h3 will come
and uh white's position collapses very
very quickly so d4 we want to play e4 we
want to close down the center
okay f3
pretty good stuff by our opponent but i
feel like it's too slow
so
we need to figure out whether we need to
respond to the tension in the center
so obviously there's a certain
temptation to play h4
but if you look more carefully you'll
see that we're just giving up the e4
pawn for nothing
so it's it's worth taking on f3 first
and then
and then going h4 to open up the h file
yeah we could play bishop h3 but that's
unnecessary
bishop h3 is unnecessary let's keep our
bishop here to
defend the pawn on d5
and now we're very close to opening the
h file
and once we open the h file
i mean
stuff is going to happen
stuff is going to go down
now that's a blunder that's just a panic
move i think our opponent trying to go
rook h1 but forgetting about bishop h3
which now wins in exchange
oh hippo violation i only understood
that now jesus
king f2
well
it's worth throwing in h takes g3 check
just to open the h file
just to open the the h12 because later
our rook may infiltrate to h2
now we take on f1 and we're just taking
everything here
okay that's another blunder our opponent
totally collapsing here uh he should
have taken with the knight
should have taken the knight but then we
would have played queen out to f5
which is obviously crushing as well and
rook takes h2 that's it
nothing remains of white's king's side
and resigns
that was pretty smooth
that was pretty smooth so notice how how
much easier it was to attack once we
completed our development at the start
of the game
so yeah it the thing about the english
is that white has a couple of ways that
that they can um
arrange
uh the pieces white can play the
immediate g3 which is sort of the
traditional english
and here c6 is a very good line
but white can also start with knight c3
and here c6 is not very good because of
d4
here c6 is not very good because of d4
so here you need a different line
and most people end up playing knight f6
although bishop b4 is also a move here
but after knight f6 g3
i have to check but i think c6 here
is still possible
so i'll look into this and i will make a
video you know with black against the
english but i'll need to do some
research and see whether c6 here is
viable or not not very well versed in
these lines
i myself have played bishop before in
this position but this is
this is a very kind of hard to analyze
line lots of sub variations and it's
you know it's not all that fun
so
anyways um but you can see that
c6 threw him in for a loop
and uh e3 is just
this is just some sort of
you know
weird hippo where pawns have been traded
and um
white is down a bunch of tempe so it's
just not
not
viable at all
and of course we could have played e4 we
could have played e4 with the idea of
going 95 and clamping down on his light
squares but then after d3 i was a little
bit concerned that again that this pawn
would become a pretty big weakness
and in the event of 95 d takes e4 i
really don't want to trade queens that
greatly diminishes the effect of us
putting a knight let's say on f3
but um
how about bishop f5 to support oh yeah
bishop f5 was an alternative to bishop
e6 for sure
but the other issue is that let's say
white castles and we play e4 at this
point white can even consider going f3
and once again trying to break down
break down this pawn
and again we're not developed on our
king sides that could end up costing us
a little bit so i you know we took the
sort of conventional approach bishop e6
queen d7 there's nothing wrong with that
and only after d4 did we play e4 to
close down the center and then we just
crushed crushed him down the h file
pretty straightforward again we won
three or four of these in the speed run
exactly in this way
if white plays h4
then it's not out of the question that
we would go g5 and just sack everything
and then go h4 even this line even h4
here
should be considered maybe it's bad but
even this is an interesting idea bishop
h1
we have h2 and bishop h3 which is
crushing
so
there is um
a lot that we can do here but we don't
have to rush with g5 we can also go for
example 97 and get this knight around to
f5
there's plenty of things that we can do
here and black is better much better in
all cases
so in any case that was a pretty simple
game all right guys i'm really tired i'm
gonna go to bed um
i will try to stream tomorrow i'll be
taking a break this week
um
but i will try to stream tomorrow around
i will try to do the second title
tuesday
um we'll see
so
yeah thank you guys this was fun
got that rating
and uh hopefully see you guys tomorrow
so thanks everybody let's read gary
and i'll see you guys
later have a good one thanks for hanging
out good night
[Music]